Thanks for joining
my talk today.
I hope you guys brought
along your shovels
since we're going to be talking
about digging a pit of success.
Over the next 15
minutes or so, I'm
going to talk about
a framework that we
developed at our
organization for developing
a pit of success.
And so let me talk a
little bit about me
before I dive into that.
So my name is Aaron Chafetz.
I work for a federal agency
called USAID as an economist,
and I work in the
Office of HIV/AIDS.
Our work in the
Office of HIV/AIDS
feeds into a larger
interagency effort
known as PEPFAR, the President's
Emergency Plan for AIDS Relief.
PEPFAR was started in 2004
with the goal of ending
the global HIV epidemic.
And we work in
interagency fashion
with a host of other agencies
like CDC, Department of Defense
and Peace Corps.
So one of the success
factors, one of the factors
that has made
PEPFAR so successful
is the reliance and
the push to collect
measurement and evaluation
data across the world.
So what does that
data look like?
We're collecting data on
HIV status, treatment status
and prevention
indicators upwards
of maybe 30 different indicators
collected at 30,000 health
facilities all across the globe.
This data also is coming
in each quarter to us.
So as you can imagine,
this adds up very quickly.
And we are swimming in data.
What makes this even
more challenging
is when you don't have the
right tools for the job.
So when I started in the Office
of HIV/AIDS back in 2015,
the primary means of
doing analysis was Excel.
Excel is great and
there's clearly
there are useful uses for it.
But when you're working with
data that come in so frequently
and are so large, it's probably
not the right tool for the job.
And at that point,
you kind of have
to recognize that there are
better things out there,
much like R.
And so that's when
I started in 2016,
started realizing that there was
a use case here for using R. I
had been using Stata
as an economist,
but even Stata stats
package didn't quite
cut it in terms of the scale of
the data we were working with.
And I got really
excited about R
and really spent a
long time learning this
and tried then to convince
other people in our organization
that R was a
great path forward
and we need to learn it.
Problem though, R has
a steep learning curve.
And so trying to convince
other people to learn R
is much like telling them, just
go out and run a marathon,
right?
It's not easy to do and
especially when you don't
have a training plan in place.
And so after a few unsuccessful
years of proselytizing R,
just talking about it,
what I realized our organization
needed was a pit of success.
We needed something
that users didn't
have to go it alone when
they were learning new skill
like R. The problem
I think in terms of
this idea of success
is we often frame it as one
of climbing a mountain, right?
We have to fight
this uphill battle.
And only when we have
summited this mountain,
after all of this work, we
have achieved something.
The idea, though,
of a pit of success
is flipping that on its head.
It's saying, why can't we
create an infrastructure
so that in order
to succeed, it's as
easy as falling into that pit?
We've and in order to do so, we
kind of lay out the guide rails
in the framework to make this
easy for other people to do.
This is by no
means a new concept
or one that I came up with.
Hadley was talking about
it way back in 2016
in relation to the
tidyverse. And the tidyverse
definitely was the primary pit
of success for me in learning R,
and I think this framework also
applies to an organization.
Problem is, if Hadley's
talking about it,
why aren't we all already
doing this already?
And I think there are
definitely some clear barriers
in the way of doing this.
Obviously, it's resource
intensive to set up this pit.
You need people to kind of
shine that light to show others
the path to move this forward.
And it's time intensive,
both for those people who
are leading the way
and for new people
to come on and learn this skill.
And then lastly, as, as
part of the government,
our hiring practices are
just definitely not as nimble
as the private sector
and our data stacks are
a little slower to innovate.
So I want to talk about
three ways in which we
were able to dig this pit of
success at our organization.
The first, the primary
means of doing so
was developing packages to
create that infrastructure,
then creating buy in
at multiple levels,
and then lastly fostering
a community of support
for R users.
So starting things off.
I think the foundations
of this pit of success
were through packages.
Our work in PEPFAR, we,
as I mentioned earlier,
have lots and lots of data,
measurement and evaluation data
that's coming in every quarter.
And this is a good means
to automate something and R
is a great tool for that, right?
So if we have this data
that's similar in coming in,
we can start writing scripts
that we can automate.
Oh, and those scripts, as
we get more comfortable,
we can turn into functions.
So that those functions are
useful to you, but they're also
can be useful to others.
And slowly I started developing
packages, initially by myself,
but I saw that this is a means
to help others enter the field
and learn R.
So as I became more
proficient in R and we started
bringing on more
people who learned R
and we had more
expertise there, we're
able to grow out
this infrastructure
to allow new people
to enter more easily.
So we've developed over time
a ton of different packages,
whether they are around
solving a problem
for a particular project
that we have to repeat,
or they're more general
utility functions
so that people don't have to
recreate the wheel every time
they encounter a problem.
So an example of this is one
of our utility packages called
glamr, where we do something
as simple as setting up
a folder structure.
Right? Doing this manually
is very easy to do.
But when you're
talking about having
to repeat this
process across lots
and lots of different
projects and doing
this across lots of
users, having something
that allows you to just fall
into that pit of success
is important.
And we do this through
a lot of different ways.
So like loading
secrets securely,
storing and loading secrets
to make it easy for people
to have all their
credentials in one place
and to make sure that they're
not posting this to GitHub
and posting their credentials.
So packages, packages really
founded the foundation
of this infrastructure because
they created reproducibility
for our work and consistency
across all of our R users.
And more importantly, this
created an approachable way
for new users to come
on without having
to know the full R ecosystem,
but they had tools that were
specific to our workflows
that they could use
and take advantage of.
So while we had those
packages, we didn't really
have the buy in and we
didn't have people clamoring
to be at the table to use R.
And where we started to be
able to turn things around
was really convincing
leadership that R
was the right direction to go.
Leadership is really
critical because they're
the ones who are
ultimately creating
that trade off structure,
telling analysts whether they
should be focusing their
attention on training
versus having to
turn around products.
Right? Because
there's always that
need for those
concrete products.
So that they can create that
influence both in the workforce
and as they're hiring new staff
on can see this as a marker
when they're looking at CVs
in order to bring that on.
And the way we were able
to lure in our leadership
was through concrete products.
We were able to and specifically
around visualizations,
we were  able to build off ggplot
by creating our own package,
glitr, that used our own
themes and colors that allowed
us to quickly and efficiently
create high quality
products that our leadership
could use to understand where
our progress was at and use
these as communication pieces.
And they wanted to see more
and more of these more quickly.
We also had to convince
our colleagues that R
is a worthwhile investment.
Right? And so I think it's clear
automation makes a ton of sense
to all of us in this room, but
there is that learning curve.
And so we needed to
convince our colleagues
that that upfront investment
cost is worthwhile
spending anywhere from
two hours to two weeks
to invest that process.
So then in a year when you're
rerunning all of these things,
it only takes seconds
to run those analyses, as
opposed to having to do
that comfort in a point
and click world where yes,
it's easy to do. You
spend 40 minutes on
it instead two weeks,
but you have to spend that
40 minutes every single time
that you're doing this.
And so the way we were
able to influence change
for our colleagues
was to curate support
to their different
workflows and intervene
in specific instances.
So maybe it was working
with a colleague
to show them how to set up
and work with them to support
an API to bring their data
in without having to do
a manual download of data.
Or maybe it was showing them
how to create calculations
before they moved their
data into Tableau.
Or maybe they felt
comfortable in the point
and click world for all of
their crunching, but then
wanted to have a high
quality product using R
for the visualization side.
So it's great.
We started to have some
buy in from our users,
but we needed then this
last piece of community.
We needed to support
them in some way.
And I think everybody here is
familiar as you've started R
or some new
programming language.
There's lots of
resources out there
and it's easy to be inundated
and overwhelmed by everything
and not sure where you
should start learning.
And so we realized
early on that we
needed to curate a
approach for them, a path
that they could move forward.
So that they knew
what direction to go
and what was applicable
for our work.
So as a result, we created
a community of practice
in our office called
corps, which is really
founded on the ideas of being
able to share our workflows
and best practices between
inexperienced users
and the ones who had
a lot more experience.
And as we developed
more and more R users,
we could do things like
having one on one mentorship
that we had people
who had been around
and knew what was going on.
We were able to develop
classroom like settings,
to have more people
able to kind of know
the 101s of R. Setting
up a Slack channel
was really important as
well because it created
a forum that people could feel
like they could ask questions
very easily and other
people could share
new things that they'd learn.
And it didn't have to
be a one way street,
like a classroom setting.
And then lastly, just
kind of setting up
infrequent like
makeover challenges.
So people became more
familiar with ggplot.
So here's kind of an example
of how we tailored our approach
in the classroom setting.
So myself and other
colleagues set up
a 12 part series that's
based R for Data Science.
The core principles from
R for data science are there,
and many of these chapters
are almost copied verbatim.
But the difference, though,
is we tailored the data
to what our analysts
were familiar with.
We used our PEPFAR data
so that an analyst
understood the funding
could focus on the
fundamentals of R
rather than having to
worry about new data.
We also tailored
all of the examples
to things that worked
in our workflow.
So that they
understood the data.
They understood these
workflows and could
go from the classroom,
like setting to apply it
the very next day in their work,
which was quite successful.
So setting up this
pit of success
was something that just
didn't happen over night
and did take a lot of time.
And it's something that we have
still been continuing to do.
And over the last few years we
have drastically, drastically
increased our user base.
But I think what's
important is not
just the number
of users we have,
but the work we've
been able to produce.
We've been able to
increase our efficiency
and do more and higher quality
work as a result of more
of an emphasis in R.
I think this model
of building a
success in creating
an infrastructure for
others in your organization
is really important.
And I'm happy to be a resource
for anybody who's trying,
feels like you are that N
of one at your organization
and wanting to set
this up. My email here
and it's in the
next slide as well.
And then I have some
additional resources
that are posted on this slide
and are also on the conference
website as well.
So with that, I'll end
and I wish any of you
who are willing to take on
this challenge the best of luck
in digging a pit of success
for your organization.